i always wanted to do a mockumentary
dude what does mine say it's sweet
what about mine dude to think about dude
where's my car i mean it's 22 years ago
holy really
i love welcome to flash it's really fun
when you guys
get this mockumentary style going do you
find that that's easier for
for comedy i thought like for my like
comedic sensibilities it would be it
would really work for me and just to be
able to use the camera to create more
comedy and or just moments
well a church moved me here from
minneapolis bit of the change i moved
here with joe then he dumped me it's a
fun challenge because i think
i think back in like
films that i've done you know you could
totally go wild and and
you can have mistakes in a take
but have some gems in there that can
they could you know slice and dice and
put it together i'll tell you one thing
though
i don't think he's gonna have a problem
at school anymore
slipped a little something into his
mochaccino
oh my gosh
so what's the secret to those asides the
looks to camera
do you like practice those ahead of time
or is it just like really in the moment
and you watch it back you're like oh
yeah though that one was good or i could
tell you the eyebrow on that one yeah
that would be really creepy just like
you know driving it's like talking
yourself and then just give yourself a
look in the mirror um
no i
i think you just kind of feel it out
you're playing father joe on the show
when i think sean williams scott i
didn't really think
reverend until
i until i saw the show and i was like oh
yeah no that makes perfect sense yeah
when you got the the notice for this for
the show and when the show first came
your way what was your reaction was you
were you sold immediately or was this
something you thought like i don't know
kind of you know what i love the bbc
show that this is based on and
obviously a huge fan of paul feig and
jenny bix
who's our
producer show runner and
um i just thought like what an amazing
dynamic do to
have behind the show but um
and then just mockumentaries i was
binging parks and rec right before you
even heard about this and i was like man
that would be such a fun show to work on
i was really went over by father joe
being a former christian boy band member
i heard that and i was like priceless
dude i mean that's like i don't care
just for me it's like love it i mean as
you see a former christian boy band
member called amen called amen there's
some dancing we i have a clip let's take
a look at this clip and then we'll and
we'll take a look at some of your sweet
moves
that's me
right there
lead singer i also did all the
choreography but of course it was the
big guy who's the lead who did you model
when he's when father joe is performing
in the boy band we've got some like
sweet bieber bangs he was a bit bieber
hobbs
and uh andy warhol and andy warhol
that's it
well i remember you look at my hair yeah
yeah very warholish i like it i like it
yeah um i read somewhere that uh paul
told you that you can't work out every
day when you're doing this is that true
no father joe's not a
not
the chiseled man that sits before women
no i got chunky i got fat not fat husky
husky husky get a little big bone yeah
big boned that's right that's safe um
yeah i know he he was just kind of i
think he or jenny they're like yeah
i can't remember what they said maybe
i'm making it up just as an excuse so i
could
just eat whatever i wanted to but i
think they're like i don't really see
father joe hitting the gym and i thought
i'm getting fat
i'm doing it eating the pizza i mean
every like mozzarella cheese sticks oh
god i got chunky very fast oh yeah
and it took me a year this is it method
acting you're like i'm going full daniel
day lewis on this yes that's what i'm
doing thank you for recognizing how
serious i take my crap committed did you
you guys were shooting in north carolina
yeah did you uh you're a married man did
you bring your wife with you
yeah i did and she was bored
really because this is it was
pre-vaccine so we were just she was like
in the house yeah she's still angry in
north carolina she hasn't talked to me
since i don't
she sends me notes you're still married
i think i'm married to my baby when
you're out in the world do people where
do you get more frequently do you get
people shouting dude
dude what does mine say or do you get
people just shouting stiffler at you i
get stiffer
i don't get you know it's kind of sad
nobody really shouts it at me anymore
they just kind of come up to me and
like hey stephanie i'm like what
happened to the shout out
that's number five and six for the stiff
meister
would you do another one yes because you
guys did the the wedding the reunion
would you do another one now like one
hundred percent do you see that
character in like mid-40s trying to
navigate the world today you know and
try to figure out like and he hasn't
grown up at all yeah and like everybody
else is growing up and
i think it would be really fun and
really funny it's showtime you need to
think about dude where's my car i mean
it's 22 years ago
holy really i mean like you ashton and
jenny garner depressed
you don't look like you've aged at all
though i've always really mattered thank
you yeah i've always literally i was
that guy in sixth grade
you're like get the old guy out yeah
nice try when you think about like the
the i mean jennifer garner and and
ashton yeah i mean like
you guys were just sort of like start
all starting out at that at that moment
to think about like yes nuts it's nuts
right that was so fun what do you
remember most about those days it was
just fun i i just i remember
just i couldn't believe that i had a
career i couldn't believe it was like
you know it's a dream come true and even
after american pie one i thought
i won the lottery if it never happens
again i'll just feel like the luckiest
kid in the world and then got another
movie and got another movie and dude
where's my car i think was like
the fourth
film
and
yeah it was i remember it really well
and just working with ashton and having
so much fun and it was such a ridiculous
like silly movie
we found the car we found the car
we found the car
[Music]
but i also remember you know working
with jennifer and we were all like
amazing like we even dan was like one of
the nicest sweetest people ever she's
gonna be massive
celebrity and talent but but it was like
it was just so much fun yeah
if you had just known back then one day
she's gonna do really excellent baking
videos on instagram you could have uh
posed yeah
there was a there were rumors of a
sequel to that floating around for a
while too seriously dude where's my car
did they was that ever a real thing or
i i don't i think so actually i think
there is like a script out there i
almost feel like you have to do it just
because the title
yes i thought dude where's my car was
maybe one of the best titles
seriously dude where's my car
pretty good pretty good pretty again
those guys at
45 years old yeah
i mean come on ashton let's do it let's
do it
sean thank you so much thank you for
your time great thank you i'm really
enjoying welcome to flash thank you
thanks so much
you